start with the first question on
capitalism
sure okay so you know you have some
famous people out there including
richard wolff famous uh socialist
economist
you have andrew yang who's currently
running for mayor of new york city
uh famous entrepreneur famous for
universal basic income and you also have
someone like ray dalio famous
billionaire hedge fund guy
who are all saying you know in a certain
extent
some saying capitalism just doesn't work
obviously the socialists and some saying
that it actually
needs to be reformed so then you have
millions of younger americans today who
have not experienced
what you've experienced we're looking at
places like canada and scandinavian
countries like norway and sweden
and they're saying well maybe this
socialism thing ain't so bad
so my question to you is mr kiyosaki
does capitalism here in america today
need to be reformed
at all in america
i don't think the problem is capitalism
the prop the problem is education
there's no financial education in our
schools i'll give a little bit of my
background
is i grew up in hawaii and i went to
i went to school in new york and i went
to military school
and at military school were taught
differently
so as the military academy one of the
five federal of military academies like
west point naval academy mine was kings
point
and the economics were taught at king's
point in the academy is different than
the economics taught in
socialist schools like harvard
and it's it's so opposite so as i said
all coins have three sides most
educators are on the socialist side like
my poor dad
yeah my poor dad worked for the peace
corps
i worked for the marine corps and so
never the twain shall meet so the reason
we have socialism on the rise
is very simply because there's no
financial education in our schools
and uh the other thing is this is what
most people don't realize
and i was a marine i fought in vietnam
twice helicopter pilot
is the people that murdered the most
people are socialists
so when you look at body counts because
as marines we always went by body count
and unfortunately our body counts were
high on both sides
but socialists have killed the most
people
and that's where we're heading to that's
my my latest book is coming out which
patrick will be part of
is called the capitalist manifesto and
the reason i'm writing capitalist
manifesto
is our schools have no idea what
socialism is
you know i mean it's tragic what's
happening
and the reason we have uh comrade biden
and comrade
kamala harris in office is they're
hardcore socialists
you know i mean biden is going to kill
more jobs than any other president in
history
then he's going to raise the minimum
wage to 15 bucks
and unemployment is going to go through
the roof and we're going to have civil
unrest
so that's why patrick and i are kind of
uh kindred spirit should we say
simpatico i would say i think he was
army
airborne ranger and all that but you
don't hold on against him do you
it's nuts anyway so we're just looking
differently
i'm not against socialism i just don't
want to be
a socialist i'd rather be a capitalist
i'm with you on that
thank you for watching this short clip
if you want to see the full episode
check it out right here and if you have
not subscribed to valuetainment
click right here